is there advice you can give about
the dark places you've gone in your mind
the depression you suffered from how to
get out from your own from your own
story
whenever i go to those really dark
places the scariest thing is that it
feels like i will never get rid of this
feeling and it is very overwhelming
um
and
i just have to kind of
look back over time spans and remember
that every single time i have got
through it and remind myself that it is
just temporary and that has been the
most helpful thing for me because i just
try to combat the scariest thing about
it
and then believe have faith that it's
gonna
like this will go away and take action
obviously to make sure it goes away and
i've also tried to spin it as depression
is one of the hardest things i've had to
deal with but also one of the biggest
motivators because if i just am left
with my own brain i get very depressed
then i really like working or focusing
on things so it actually pushed me to
you know try to focus on school try to
focus on chess focus on whatever i'm
doing and also if i'm feeling really bad
then there's probably something a little
bit off and i use it as a signal and try
to think of it as okay this is just a
sign that there's things that could be
improved for long term
what about you andrea have you gone to
dark places in your mind
i'd say i
my family like like i see alex going
through this my mom also has very
serious depression luckily i got the
genes where i don't go through that
serious level of depression that they do
i say mine is much more temporarily so
it's more similar to what what i was
feeling when i was exactly you're like
yes exactly where like but i know that
it's not something that's clinical and
that's
just a
genetic thing or a mental thing whereas
i know it's more serious for like my
family members um and i did relate a lot
with you where you're saying where that
really pushes you and i felt that a lot
through content where you just kind of
feel
hopeless
and kind of like an existential crisis
where i don't like the content i'm doing
and that's what pushes me to like okay
you have no choice but to try something
that now you're gonna be passionate
about because otherwise you're gonna be
stuck in this never-ending cycle um so
it does it's short-term and then um it
helps me come up with the things that i
enjoy the most content-wise and it also
long-term taught me just how to have a
more balanced life like doing small
things that make me happier on a daily
basis to like working out to eating
healthier which i notice when i don't do
for weeks i just get a lot more
depressed
you